several people have been killed and
injured in what police are calling a
serious firearms incident in plymouth
local residents in kiam are said to have
heard loud bangs and gunshots when
emergency services including hazardous
area response teams arrived on site
the police have issued the following
statement
police were called to a serious firearms
incident in biddick drive in the kihim
area of plymouth at around 6 10 p.m
today
officers and ambulance staff attended
there have been a number of fatalities
at the scene and several other
casualties are receiving treatment a
critical incident has been declared
the area has been cordoned off and
police believe the situation is
contained we are appealing to the public
not to speculate or share pictures of
the scene on social media or anywhere
else
the home secretary priti patel has
tweeted the incident in plymouth is
shocking and my thoughts are with those
affected i've spoken to the chief
constable and offered my false support
i urge everyone to remain calm follow
police advice and allow our emergency
services to get on with their jobs
well let's speak to skies christine
megson now who's at the scene christine
tell us exactly what you can see
the suburb of bristol of uh plymouth
there are just flashing blue police
lights and a police cordon three
officers standing on the cordon
looking further down the road i can see
two more police cars and i understand
there's a police carrier further down
the road um but yes all very quiet
indeed we've spoken to some eyewitnesses
here on the street who said that
they heard a loud bang similar to a car
back firing just after quarter past six
here this evening um
obviously there's been a great deal of
speculation on social media but it seems
from local reports that this just may be
a
tragic uh domestic incident police
obviously not giving up any further
updates at this point
and have people been cleared from the
streets as far as you can tell
there's no official there's a police
line cordoning off the actual road where
the incident took place but we're
standing in the surrounding streets
which are incredibly quiet and there's
everybody's in their homes there's
nobody on the street it's very very
quiet indeed and eerily quiet in fact
okay for the moment thank you thanks for
bringing that to us let's speak now to
our home affairs correspondent
mark white who's also following events
um what are your sources telling you
mark
well nothing as yet on the potential
cause of reason behind this very serious
firearms incident
but what uh sources are telling me is at
this stage they are not treating it as a
terrorist related incident there is no
information
to point to any terrorist motivation
but clearly a very significant incident
that unfolded just after six o'clock in
the evening
in this area of plymouth to the north of
plymouth in a road called biddick drive
that the emergency services were called
to
to reports of a shooting incident and we
heard that from christine about
eyewitnesses reporting multiple gunshots
there are a number of people reporting
the same and clearly that is borne out
by
the
interim uh preliminary casualty figures
that are coming through
from the emergency services with the
police confirming a number of fatalities
and a number of people being treated for
injuries as well now a source is telling
me that the number of fatalities could
be as high as 5.
a slight caveat to that as always in the
early stages of an incident like this
the numbers can be
a bit fluid but it's it's possible they
believe that up to five people may have
been killed in this incident including
the gunman we're told
who was shot now we don't know at this
stage whether that gunman uh was shot
and died of self-inflicted injuries or
whether they were involved in a police
involved shooting but of course devon
and cornwell armed response units were
very quickly on scene uh they will
always be called to a firearms incident
will be the ones who push forward trying
to deal with any threat that's out there
before they can then allow the other
emergency services in to deal with the
casualties on the ground and a
significant number of course of
casualties with the southwestern
ambulance service confirming to us that
they deployed at 12 minutes past six in
the evening they sent their hazardous
area uh response teams those heart teams
now these are the paramedics that have
specialist uh top tier training to be
able to deal with the most serious of
incidents they attended along with a
number of doctors paramedic vehicles of
course and a number of air ambulances as
well
lots of other police that were there uh
non-armed officers who couldn't push
forward until the scene was declared
safe we're told by devon and cornwall
constabulary that they have the
situation contained now so uh believing
that they have neutralized the threat
but of course they still have a very
active crime scene and although it was
very quiet where christine was
that's only because when the police get
control of the situation they push the
cordon further and further back so the
activity in terms of the the the
immediate crime scenes around biddick
drive uh is very busy indeed with lots
of forensic teams there
lots of police including armed police
still around that area piecing together
the exact circumstances of what happened
but the home secretary tonight
describing it as a very shocking
sequence of events and allowing uh and
appealing to the public to allow the
emergency services to get on with their
very vital work
okay mark for the moment uh thank you